[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité au sommaire de ce
journal nous reviendrons sur les mesures
annoncées par Gabriel hatal ministre de
l'éducation nationale pour relever le
niveau des élèves français des mesures
qui sont loin de faire l'unanimité comme
a pu le constater vous le verrez via
occcitanie en déplacement à fauxse
surmer le ministre de la transition
énergétique lui a rappelé les promesses
de l'État pour une décarbonation
optimale en 2050 et confirmer
l'implantation du parc éolien flottant à
notre partenaire de la Provence nous
sommes à 10 jours de Noël et il est
encore temps d'écrire au Père Noël au
total son secrétariat officiel installé
à Libourne traitera plus d'un million de
lettres et courriels TV7 la chaîne du
groupe sud-ouest nous fera découvrir cet
endroit interdit aux enfants enfin nous
irons avec tél Nantes visiter une
exposition exceptionnelle qui aura
nécessité 6 ans de travail et de
négociation au cœur du quartier médiéval
de Nantes le Château des Ducs de
Bretagne accueille une exposition
inédite consacrée à
jjiscan commençons ce grand gité des
territoires avec le chantier de
rénovation de Notre-Dame de Paris qui
vous vous en souvenez avec subit un
incendie majeur en avril 2019 plus de
1000 artisans à travers la France
participent à ce chantier titanesque un
an de sa réouverture le chantier de
Notre-Dame vient de passer une étape
très importante la restitution de la
flèche pour est France Philippe Mirkovic
et Gabriel Chanéac ont rencontré l'un
des charpentiers en charge de cette
rénovation exceptionnelle regardez alors
là on se trouve dans la charpente du
cœur de Notre-Dame de Paris donc c'est
les charpentes médiévales euh qui ont
été faites en bois vert à partir
d'arbres sélectionnés en France du CH
notamment et on peut retrouver des
assemblages traditionnels donc c'est
surtout des des assemblages sonelon
morthèz chevillers en bois les mesures
annoncées par Gabriel Attal ministre de
l'éducation nationale pour relever le
niveau des élèves français sont loin de
faire l'unanimité si les parents
d'élèves veulent garder le dernier mot
sur le possible redoublement de leur
enfant les professeurs eux demandent
plus de moyens dès le premier degré pour
combler les lacunes avant l'entrée au
collège le point avec Antoine Guillet
pour VI
occitan des mesures fortes annoncées par
le gouvernement et au cœur des débats le
redoublement dont le dernier Moot
appartiendra désormais au professeurs il
s'agira pas de faire du redoublement
voilà systématique bien évidemment au
contraire de pouvoir proposer des
solutions comme des cours
d'approfondissement ou de soutien comme
je viens de le voir comme aussi des
stages de réussite pendant les congés
scolaires et si nécessaire parce que ça
serait une clé pour une meilleure
réussite ensuite proposer le
redoublement une mesure Phard décriée
par les parents d'élèves aujourd'hui des
tenteur de ce dernier mot les recherches
ont montré que finalement le
redoublement imposé aux élèves était
contreproductif parce que pour qu'il
puisse fonctionner il faut que les
jeunes soient d'accord pour aller vers
ce redoublement et sinon et ça leur fait
perdre de l'estime en eux-mêm et puis
finalement ça ne prod pas les effets
attendus donc nous sommes étonnés que le
ministre il veuille insister sur ce
point qui a été assez déccrié par les
chercheurs en éducation parmi les autres
mesures phares annoncées la refonde de
certains programmes scolaires
l'obtention obligatoire du brevet pour
accéder au lycée ou encore la création
de groupe de niveau au collège pour les
cours de mathématiques et de français un
panel de mesures pas suffisant pour les
professeurs il réclame plus d'effectifs
dès le premier degré on se retrouve avec
de grandes difficultés les enfants ne
sont pas suivis n'ont pas de soins n'ont
pas d'aide ni extérieure ni au sein de
l'éducation nationale on manque de
psycholog scolaire on manque de maîtres
supplémentaires qui viennent prendre en
charge les difficultés des enfants les
troubles du comportement et tout ça est
un lien aussi avec les difficultés
rencontrées et qui arrivent en 6e et la
réponse que vous avez pu entendre déjà
depuis cet été c'est le PACT avec du
soutien en 6e qui pour nous de toute
façon arrive beaucoup trop tard les
difficultés scolaires doivent être
prises charge dès la maternelle des
enseignants désabusés il prévoi une
journée d'action pour manifester leur
mécontentement courant du mois de
janvier entre 800 et un millier de
personnes ont manifesté une nouvelle
fois leur opposition à la construction
de l'autoroute a69 prévue entre Toulouse
et castre le cortège a dévié du parcours
annoncé pour envahir le site de la
future usine d'enrobé à puis Laurence
dans le Tarne les différents collectifs
citoyens et locaux créés contre les
centrales habitum dénoncent les risques
que pour la santé pour l'environnement
présenté par les fumées de ces
installations provisoires qui vont
produire le revêtement de l'autoroute
pendant plusieurs mois partons
maintenant dans la Loire où le groupe de
distribution casino est né il y a 125
ans en difficulté financière le groupe
fondé par geoffroid Guichard vite un
avenir incertain à Saint-Étienne siège
historique du groupe et qui emploie
environ 400 personnes dans le
département notre partenaire TL7 dans la
Loire a suivi la manifestation
ind l'affluence était forte ce mardi des
9h du matin devant le siège de casino
dans le quartier de Château crereux un
millier d'employés s réunis pour
s'élever contre un démentellement
redouté du groupe au 125 ans d'existence
je suis pas la seule mais on a des crit
à côté on a on a certain situation de
famille on on des enfants donc voilà
c'est ça devient compliqué beaucoup de
salari se posent des questions sur leur
leur avenir ce que le groupe compte
faire des salariés de ce que qui va
reprendre qui va reprendre les les
magasins si on va être racheté si on va
être vendu un cortège dans lequel des
Stéphanois pas nécessairement salarié du
groupe se montrait simplement solidaire
parce qu'à mon âge on a vu Manu France
s'arrêter on a vu la sidérurgie se
démanteler aujourd'hui on voit une
nouvelle épine dorsale qui est menacée
et c'est derrière le portrait de
Geoffroy Guichard que des élus se
trouvaient en première ligne du cortège
aujourd'hui le premier enjeu c'est celui
des emplois sur ces ventes des hyper
l' suivant celui de la proximité à
travers la
logtique la marque de référence et de
l'ensemble du réseau de distribution qui
pour qui devra rester fort derrière et
ensuite l'offre de reprise de l'ensemble
du groupe Monoprix Fran prix et aut
c'est extrêmement for et à la fin de la
manifestation des leaders syndicaux ont
été reçus par le maire de Saint-Étienne
forcément un qu pour l'un des plus gros
employeurs de la ville avec 2000
personnes rien qu'au siège de casino on
se demande ce qui va rester à la fin
tout simplement il y a une relation
affective très forte entre on a tous des
des des membres de notre famille qui
travaillent au casino hein donc au-delà
de ça je dirais que c'est un grand
groupe national et ça regarde
effectivement jusqu'au président de la
République l'avenir du groupe Casino au
moment où la COP 28 se termine Agnès
panier runaché la ministre de la
transition énergétique s'est rendu à
fausse surmer dans les Bouches du Rône
afin de confirmer l'implantation de
trois éoliennes flottantes d'une
puissance de 8,4 MW chacune une annonce
que les pêcheurs locaux ont du mal à
accepter rudida ont été sur place pour
la Provence regardez c'est le deuxè parc
etolien marin de France qui est venu
visiter aujourd'hui agè panier runché à
Port debouc un projet test qui pourra
notamment permettre une expérimentation
sur l'impact de T structure sur le
milieu marin nous sommes devant ce
projet d'éolienne flottante qui
constitue une expérimentation mais qui
est emblématique de ce que nous sommes
en train de construire c'est-à-dire
c'est un un projet qui a été conçu
notamment avec de l'ingénierie française
et qui va nous donner énormément
d'informations sur les enjeux de
biodiversité sur les enjeux de
conciliation des différents usages de la
mer pourtant les pêcheurs de la région
sont inquiet il dénonce une
privatisation de l'espace marin c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on est assez peu de
retour sur l'impact que ça peut avoir
sur le la ressource et sur les habitats
on sait aujourd'hui que ces zones ne
seront pas ouvertes au chalut
ni au palangre dérivant qui cible le ton
rouge faut savoir que ici à PGL il y
avait quotidiennement des chalutiers
mais également des palangriers qui
viennent de 7 et du gros du roi qui
travaillaient tous les jours dans ces
zones on est en grande concertation et
en discussion depuis des années avec la
pêche professionnelle et en particulier
la prudomie de martig et on est en
discussion avec eux pour voir
effectivement ensuite les zones
d'évitement il y a une zone d'évitement
de de 100 m autour des éoliennes nous
anticipons c'est-à-dire que ce débat
nous le menons pour des projets qui vont
voir le jour en 2031 et le retour sur
l'éoliens flottant on est en train de le
construire vous savez que il y a un
projet enfin à saint-nazer qu'il y a ce
projet qui est en large au large des
côtes Méditerranées et que nous allons
continuer à consolider les informations
dont nous disposons aussi sur des
projets qui sont réalisés en Europe
notamment le projet écossais qui
aujourd'hui est celui pour lequel nous
nous avons pas mal de recul et pas mal
d'études et ce que montre les
différentes études que nous consolidons
progressivement c'est que on sait
concilier la biodiversité la pêche et la
production d'énergie ce parc de trois
éoliennes marines produira courant 2024
de l'électricité pour une ville de la
taille de martig et pourrait même
s'agrandir dans les années à
venir revenu naturellement en France par
l'Italie il y a près de 50 ans la
présence du loup gris sur nos
territoires suscite de nombreuses
crispations NOTAM notamment chez les
éleveurs qui dénoncent régulièrement ces
attaques comment cohabiter avec les
loups c'est la question que se pose
inlassablement Jean-Michel Bertrand
naturaliste et réalisateur de
documentaire c'est le cœur du sujet de
son dernier film venant clore une
trilogie vivre avec les loups notre
partenaire VOG TV l'a
rencontré comment cohabiter avec les
loups la question que se pose
inlassablement Jean-Michel Bertrand avec
son dernier film venant clore une
trilogie vivre avec les loups le
naturaliste réalisateur depuis un refuge
dans une vallée perdue des Alpes le
constate six familles de loup se
partagent désormais un vaste territoire
pourtant au 19e siècle l'homme l'avait
éradiqué mais c'est aussi l'homme qui a
contribué à son retour
inéluctable depuis l'Italie le super
prédateur a recolonisé le sud-est de la
France il y a eu vraiment un
retournement de la part de l'État qui a
décidé d'organiser de vastes pl
reboisement les loups ont disparu à
cause de nous et ils sont revenus à
cause d'un changement de comportement et
être pour ou contre les les loup c'est
vrai que c'est bah c'est complètement
surréaliste aujourd'hui ce film démontre
la faculté du loup à s'adapter on encit
entre 1000 et 1500 en France et sa
dispersion progresse alors comment vivre
avec dépassant les polémiques
Jean-Michel Bertrand est allé à la
rencontre notamment des bergers en
première ligne avec leurs chiens et
l'aide de bénévoles pour pour surveiller
les troupeaux plus étonnant en Italie
dans la vallée des abruses le loup est
devenu un produit d'appel touristique le
souci aujourd'hui dans les abruses c'est
de gérer les touristes c'est pas de
gérer les prédateurs et économiquement
c'est énorme donc aujourd'hui ilrait à
l'aider à personne là-bas d'éradiquer
les loups parce que c'est tout
simplement un business mais le loup
c'est aussi faire preuve
d'autorégulation le nombre de loup
dépend de la ressource c'està-dire des
proies potentielles la territorialité
donc si les Voges sont moins adaptés au
loup mais il y aura évidemment moins de
loup que dans les Alpes mais c'est pas
nous qui choisissons c'est eux pour
Jean-Michel Bertrand le loup est un
animal politique un indicateur de la
capacité humaine à accepter la nature
dont il nous livre une fois encore toute
la beauté dans ce film sortie nationale
le 24
janvier Caroline fruchot versaillaise de
30 ans a choisi de vivre intensément
malgré son handicap victime d'un
accident de ski 2018 la jeune femme est
aujourd'hui paraplégique mais multiplie
les projets les plus fous vous allez le
voir basket parapante surf ou encore
entrepreneuriat portrait d'une femme
bien décidée à faire tomber les préjugés
sur les personnes en fauteuil c'est une
belle rencontre que nous raconte tv78
dans les ivelines là c'est du waveski et
là c'est quand on est allé au
monts-michel donc avait un hand bike et
là c'est petite partie de karting et là
c'est pas parachute dans parapente ici
une vie palpitante au-delà du handicap
sport sorti entre amis ou travail
Caroline fruchot savoure Chac instant de
son existence en mai 2018 cette
versaillaise victime d'un accident de
ski àtigne et devient paraplégique une
lésion de la moelle épinière entraînant
une paralysie des deux membres
inférieurs hospitalisée durant 8 mois à
Garche la jeune femme de 30 ans peut
compter sur la présence indéfectible de
ses proches le fait de les revoir de
savoir qu'ils étaient toujours là
d'avoir leur soutien bah ça m'a aussi
énor mment porté Lefin avec ma famille
mes amis tout l'entourage qui était
aussi présent et en réalité je me suis
battu pour moi mais je je me suis aussi
battu pour eux suite à son accident
Caroline met un terme à sa carrière de
pâtissière elle monte sa propre
entreprise et créé hostobox en 2021 une
boîte garnie de gâteau de jeux ou de
soins du corps un concept inspiré des
colis surprise qu'elle recevait de sa
famille durant son hospitalisation
l'idée avec hostobox en fait c'est
vraiment d'essayer dégayer le quotidien
des personnes qui sont hospitalisées de
permettre en fait à des proches qui
veulent avoir une petite attention pour
leur bah pour la personne qu'elles vont
voir à l'hôpital que ça soit autre chose
qu'un bouquet de fleurs ou qu'une
tablette de chocolat toujours se
surpasser à l'été 2021 elle se lance
avec sa sœur dans un périple d'une
dizaine de jours entre Versailles et le
monts-michel 400 km sur ce vélo à la
seule force des bras un défi sportif
pour donner un autre regard sur le
handicap toutes les personnes en fait
qu'ont rencontré c'était vraiment de les
de les sensibiliser de pouvoir leur
montrer que quand on est en fauteil
roulant et ben en fait la vie elle est
pas terminée et qu'on peut quand même
toujours faire des choses dans notre
quotidien et qu'il est aussi hyper riche
voire peut-être même plus riche pour
certaines personnes que des personnes
valides quoi on va dire à l'avenir
Caroline aimerait parcourir le tour de
la Corse à vélo ou descendre la Vallée
Blanche à ski dans le massif du
Montblanc des projets plein la tête pour
montrer la voix et prouver que le
handicap n'est pas une
barrière voilà c'est un moment important
dans dans l'année le Noël solidaire
organisé au man offre au plus démunis
l'occasion de célébrer cette période pas
toujours facile lorsque l'on vit dans la
rue au programme un plat chaud cuisiné
par un chef étoilé des dons de vêtements
du sourire mais aussi l'opportunité de
se faire coiffer dans ces moments-là des
liens peuvent se créer et perdurer c'est
la belle histoire contée par Colin
montsel pour LM TV
Sart des retrouvailles heureuses ces
deuxlà se sont rencontrés en juin 2011
place deses à l'occasion d'une coupe de
cheveux pour les sans ABR et les plus
démunis lendemain
elle avait peur de le rater mais avec
tout le compenson que j'ai filé tout le
soutien tout le reste quoi elle a eu son
truc lendemain ben pare la BAN jusqu'à
là quoi voilà je stressa il m'a rassuré
il m'a raconté son parcours et c'est
vrai qu'en fait moi je l'ai regardé je
me suis dit je me plains mais pourquoi
je me plains moi j'ai tout il a rien et
à l'heure actuelle c'est lui qui est
plus heureux que moi et c'est là que je
me suis dit stop ça a créé énormément de
lien c'est vraiment quelqu'un de très
proche à l'heure actuelle après cet
épisode il se revoit déjeunent ensemble
même s'il ne se côtoi pas tous les jours
il compte l'un pour l'autre moi j'ai
toujours son numéro de téléphone elle
est toujours le mien j'espère s'il a un
problème c'est très bien elle peut me
contacter c'est ce type de lien unique
que promut cette soirée solidaire
organisée par l'association un regard un
sourire un toit une histoire qui a aussi
marqué la carrière professionnelle
d'anaï les personnes comme Anthony il
nous ont fait confiance dès le premier
instant et du coupah ça nous amène de la
confiance en soi et c'est vrai que bah
après on évolue qu c'est aussi pour ça
qu'Antony est venu après 3 ans et demi
dans la rue il vit dans un logement mais
sa présence était nécessaire si tu veux
c'est une visite de aussi pour faire
comprendre mes proches m proches entre
guillemets que je suis toujours là
toujours vivanton voilà tout va bien
important pour tous les proches de le
savoir cette période tout va bien à
bientôt merci beaucoup
Noël voilà la première réponse du Père
Noël aux enfants fut écrite par
Françoise Dolto la célèbre pédiatre et
depuis c'est une tradition chaque année
àbourne ouvre le secrétariat du Père
Noël à 15 jours du réveillon les enfants
doivent faire au plus vite pour envoyer
leur liste au Père Noël alors pour la
61e édition c'est un célèbre auteur de
roman à succès qui prête sa plume pour
accompagner avant sa grande tournée le
Père Noël notre partenaire TV7 nous fait
découvrir ce lieu magique quand je pense
à toi j'aurisie tes lettre et ça me
touche énormément je te fais des gros
bisous à la Mère Noël aussi au lutin et
également à terraen comme la lettre du
petit d'Orient 3 ans c'est entre les
mains de ces 60 lutines qu'arrivent tous
les courriers venus du monde entier
c'est émouvant parce qu'on on voit qu'
qu'il adore la période de Noël qu'il y
pense tout le long de l'année et
secrétariat du Père Noël aucune lettre
ne reste sans réponse par rapport à
l'actualité c'est vrai que ça fait du
bien d'avoir de mois où on reçoit
énormément de lettres d'amour parce que
les enfants ou les adultes qui nous
écrivent envoient beaucoup de messages
d'amour c'est vrai que ça fait du bien
de pouvoir aussi rendre l'amour que les
enfants et les personnes qui nous
écrivent nous donnent nous transmettent
dans leur courrier je t'envoie ma petite
liste comme prévu gros bisous Père Noël
console de jeux ou même animaux de
compagnie le Père Noël reçoit jusqu'à
40000 courriers par jour et s'engage à
répondre gratuitement à tous les enfants
depuis 1962 cette démarche est montée en
puissance validée par la pédopsychiatre
Françoise Dolto ça a démarré avec
quelques milliers de courriers dans les
années 50 les années 60 pour aujourd'hui
avoir plus d'unliion 300000 envoies
prévu cette année leel aussi s'est
inspiré et appppuy sur Michel busy qui
est un écrivain un auteur bien bien
connu et reconnu pour effectivement
devenir sa plume et c'est lui qui a
écrit le courrier de réponse que
recevront tous les enfants un dernier
conseil écrire avant le 20 décembre
prochain car vous l'imaginez bien le
père Noël a beaucoup de
travail pour satisfaire les demandes des
petits et des grands il n'est pas
obligatoire non nécessaire d'aller bien
loin mode marocinerie déco et si on
acheté français pour ces fêtes pour 20
minutes TV Antoine Boitel a rencontré
Émilie R la coffondatrice du mouvement
des jours
tricolor le made in France il y a un
prix juste il y a un prix qui reflète un
savoir-faire qui reflète un emploi qui
reflète une économie et qui reflète
aussi une qualité donc le made in France
n on a souvent tendance à dire que c'est
un investissement vous payez certes en
valeur faciale un petit peu plus cher
que dans que dans la f fashion c'est
certain mais c'est pas plus cher que
dans la plupart des boutiques moyen de
gamme que que vous allez croiser dans
Paris et du coup vous vous investissez
vraiment à la fois sur une qualité de
produit qui va rester un intemporel un
produit qui va vous rendre fier qui va
vous apporter du bonheur et vous n'avez
pas besoin d'en avoir 36 il y a pas
besoin d'avoir 36 t-shirts dans sa
garde-robe il vous en suffit de
quelquesuns mais qui ont vraiment du
sens et qui vous accompagneront pendant
très longtemps en cette période de de
fêes le spectacle vivant est à l'honneur
en haut de savoix et particulièrement à
anemas une vingtaine de compagnies venu
de toute l'Europe vont se succéder a
dans les rues de la capitale du jeune
voie français à l'occasion du festival
bonjour L'hiver pour 8 Montblanc Fanny
savar assister au premier spectacle de
rue
regardez à la tombée de la nuit Anma se
transforme en scène de spectacle à ciel
ouvert comme chaque année depuis 27 ans
le Festival d'Art de rue bonjour L'hiver
anime le centreville jusqu'au 24
décembre c'était une volonté des élus à
la naissance du festival de pouvoir
proposer bah voilà un moment culturel au
moment de Noël et pas se contenter que
d'une fête commerciale d'où l'envie à ce
moment-là de pouvoir proposer des
spectacles de des arts de la rue et donc
on confie la programmation chaque année
au Théâtre de la toupine qui a éviantles
bains et qui donc nous propose de tout
un tas de spectacles sur la période donc
là cette année c'est une vingtaine de
compagnies qui vont être présentes qui
viennent de toute l'Europe on en a une
qui arrive derrière moi en
fanfare une cinquantaine de
manifestations prendront place dans les
rues chaque mercredi samedi et dimanche
de décembre pour cette 27e édition des
spectacles de pyrotechnie d'acrobatie ou
encore de magie sont au programme de
quoi émerveiller petits et grands il y
avait des tours de
magie des spectacles des gens qui jouent
c'est la première fois que je suis en
métropole et donc oui c'est une
découverte pour moi en même temps on est
venu pour découvrir un petit peu ce que
le village Noël proposait en même temps
balader avec les enfants nous on vient
chaque année depuis qu'ils sont tout
petits et bah parce que chaque année les
spectacles chant pas tout le temps on
aime un peu tout les lumières les
animaux et la diversité des animations
le spectacle des animaux fantastiques
très attendus des anmatiens ouvreit le
bal place de l'Hôtel de Ville ce
mercredi 6 décembre ces créatures
mythique et illuminées qui tour à tour
s'amuse avec des killes joue avec le feu
ou réalise des acrobaties ont
impressionné les enfants moi là-bas je
suis venu pour la ptinoir mais j'ai hte
qu' a les animaux fantastiques un
démarrage réussi pour bonjour L'hiver
qui compte bien continuer de faire
briller les yeux des enfants jusqu'à
l'arrivée du Père
Noël c'est une première en France et une
exposition exceptionnelle après 6 ans de
travail et de négociation compliqué avec
le gouvernement chinois le Château des
Ducs de Bretagne présente son exposition
sur jjis scan le grand conquérant mongol
de l'époque médiévale regardez ce
reportage de notre partenaire sur place
tél c'est la première exposition
française consacrée à gen scan avec son
armée il va au 13e siècle fonder le plus
grand empire au monde allant de la Chine
à la Méditerranée soit près d'un quart
de la planète cette exposition permet de
voir et comprendre l'histoire mongole
comment ils ont influencé et changé la
face du monde je découvre cette
exposition qui est plutôt bien agancé
très lisible avec beaucoup
d'explications bien éclairé bien mise en
scène donc ça c'est plutôt une bonne
découverte j'imaginais pas que de façon
aussi ancienne il y avait des choses
aussi magnif
dans l'AR en fait j'ai j'ai été
impressionné par les les toutes
premières pièces le début de l'expo
souvent représenté comme un Conquérent
sanguinaire qui détruit tout sur son
passage jengiskan est également un homme
politique ouvert à la diplomatie il est
favorable aux échanges entre cultures il
impose une tolérance religieuse et met
en place des mesures égalitaires il
octroie notamment les mêmes droits aux
femmes qu'aux hommes c'est un nom qui
faisait peur justement
et ben voilà j'apprends autre chose sur
lui et puis surtout la tolérance qu'il
avait avec toutes les religions je suis
très surprise et la place des femmes
aussi je suis très très très surprise
par par ce monde monter cette exposition
JJ scan a été un véritable parcours du
combattant une première version
organisée avec la Chine a d'abord été
annulé en 2020 trop de censur imposé
c'est donc avec le soutien de la
Mongolie que Nant peut aujourd'hui
proposer cette exposition c'est une
vraie délivrance vous avez C 6 ans de
travail 6 ans de négociation 6 ans
d'obstacles avec une accélér grâce à la
collaboration de de l'État mongolle qui
a mis à disposition ces chefdœuves oui
c'est une grande satisfaction
aujourd'hui de pouvoir ouvrir cette
exposition les pièces exposées sont
d'une très grande valeur certaines n'ont
jamais été montrées en Occident leur
installation a été surveillée de près
faut évidemment pas les casser faut
aussi les mettre en en sécurité et tout
ça se fait sous un protocole extrêmement
strict puisque les musées viennent avec
ce qu'on appelle des convoyeurs ils
accompagnent l'objet ils nous aide à
mettre l'objet il surveille les
conditions d'exposition de sécurité la
lum lumière la température l'rométrie le
musée d'ouand Bator a largement
contribué à cette
exposition cette rencontre des
différents objets en fait occidental et
mongol permet de comprendre et voir et
comprendre
l'histoire de l'empire mongol de manière
complète l'exposition jengisc comment
les Mongols ont changé le monde c'est
donc jusqu'au 5 mai 2024 au Château des
Ducs de
Bretagne voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition merci à vous suivi on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition du Grand JIT des territoires au
revoir à
[Musique]
tous